[music playing]
My name is Justin Workman.
I'm 39.
And I've been bladesmithing
for roughly four years.
The last three months, I've
been going through chemo
with the hopes that it
would stave off the need
for amputation of my right arm.
I hope this sets an example
to anybody that's struggling.
No matter how bad it is, you
can still power through it.
My name is Doug Zegel.
I'm from Mount
Laurel, New Jersey.
I'm 33 years old.
My uncle was a blacksmith.
So I got to move some metal
with him when I was younger.
And I really enjoyed it.
You took something rock hard,
like steel, you heat it up,
and it's like Play-Doh.
I mean, what's cooler than that?
GRADY POWELL: Justin,
Doug, congratulations.
You guys made it past
round one and two.
And now it's just
between the two of you
for the title of "Forged
in Fire" Champion
and a check for $10,000.
In round three of
the competition,
we're going to send you home
to make another culinary tool.
But this one is
quite a bit bigger
than anything you've seen.
And that tool is
the maguro bocho.
NARRATOR: Also known
as the tuna sword,
the maguro bocho
is a specialized
cutting tool designed to
fillet massive bluefin tuna.
This impressive blade is not
your average kitchen cutlery.
With a total length
up to three feet long,
these culinary swords
were often hand
forged by the same
swordsmiths that made
the iconic Japanese katana.
They feature a thick
spine and razor-sharp
edge that cuts effortlessly
through any large fish.
The maguro bocho is still used
today by some Japanese chefs
and can be seen on
full display at some
of Tokyo's iconic fish markets.
Now, when you guys
build your blades,
I want you to follow
these parameters.
Your blade length needs to
be between 29 and 31 inches.
You need to have a
single-edge chisel grind.
And I also want
you to incorporate
a ricasso between the
handle and the blade.
I'm feeling pretty nervous.
I'm going to have to forge the
longest blade I've ever made.
Gentlemen, we'll see
you guys in four days.
Good luck.
- All right.
Good luck, man.
We're here at my home forge
in Chambersburg, Pennsylvania.
My game plan is, I'm
going to san mai.
Give her a little flux.
JUSTIN WORKMAN (VOICEOVER):
heat treat is the biggest
thing I'm concerned with.
My goal is to get
a hardened blade.
Oh, I got a nice little
warp in that bad boy.
Oh, I'm so mad.
JUSTIN WORKMAN (VOICEOVER):
whole competition did
not go exactly as I planned.
Got about four hours
left of this competition,
and I still have a fair
amount of work to do.
I know for a fact
that I met parameters.
It's the one thing
that I've been checking
over, and over, and over again.
DOUG ZEGEL: I'm back in
Mount Laurel, New Jersey,
at my home forge.
And I am ready to get started
on my maguro bocho build.
So this tuna sword is
probably about twice as long
as anything I've ever made.
I gotta get the forge hot.
And I'm ready to put my 80CRV2
in there and get hammering.
It's pretty malleable steel.
So, so far things are
going pretty quickly.
But I want to keep making
progress as fast as possible.
Once the quench
comes, that's kind
of the make-or-break
situation for me today.
So I'm just trying to
get the heat right.
Yeah, we're in good shape.
It's time to get everything
fit and assembled
and finish this blade.
All right.
Got a nice, clean fit.
That is the first look at what
will soon be a finished blade.
Now that I have the
final assembly finished--
I didn't come up with
an elaborate test.
But I used to work in
a sushi restaurant,
and this is a tuna sword.
It cut pretty clean.
I think it does the job.
All right, bladesmiths.
To find out what
kind of lethal damage
your magura bochos will
do, I'll take your weapon
and make some lethal cuts on
these six different fishes.
Justin, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Let's make some sushi.
[heavy metal music]
Way to go, man.
Thanks.
DOUG MARCAIDA:
All right, Justin.
Let's talk about
your weapon here.
First up, your edge--
one-and-done for
all the cuts here.
It's a very sharp edge.
I like the handle
construction here.
It's ovoid, so my hand matches
nicely and wraps around it.
Overall, sir, it will kill.
Thank you.
All right, Doug,
you're up next.
You ready?
Have at it.
Let's do it.
[heavy metal music]
Nicely job, man.
It's all right.
All right, Doug.
First up, the handle
construction--
I really like the way you
shaped your handle here.
It's typical Japanese style.
Now, it's a lighter blade.
But your edge is so sharp, it
cut cleanly through the fishes
easily.
Overall, sir, it will kill.
Thanks.
DAVID BAKER: All
right, gentlemen.
I think you know
what time it is.
It's time for the strength test.
And we're calling this
our bo staff attack.
Now, Justin, your weapon is
already locked in our device
here, and I will be attacking
it with our wax wood bo staffs.
This test is not about what
your blades do to that staff,
but what that staff's
gonna do to your blade.
JUSTIN WORKMAN: All right.
- Y'all ready?
Let's do it.
OK.
[heavy metal music]
All right, Justin.
You know, this is a brutal
test for what is technically
a large kitchen knife.
But you did very, very well.
Right where my finger is,
there's the smallest of chips.
And it's-- when I say
"smallest of chips,"
I mean, it's really small.
Everything else looks
right and tight.
All in all, you did a great job.
You survived.
Thank you.
DAVID BAKER: You bet.
All right, Doug.
You're up.
You ready?
As ready as I can be.
OK, because this
is fun for me.
DOUG ZEGEL: These blades are
narrow, really thin blades.
It is not designed
to take any abuse.
I'm already thinking that
Justin's got this test won.
[heavy metal music]
So Doug, right off,
this is remarkably light.
There is the
slightest rough spot.
But besides that, I don't see
any deformation in your blade.
Blade's as straight as it
was when we started out.
It's a good, solid piece.
Well done.
Thank you.
DAVID BAKER: So all
right, gentlemen.
Two tests down and
one test to go.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, bladesmiths,
we're cutting it close.
We know that both
your weapons can kill
and we know they're strong.
Now's the time to find
out how sharp they are.
This is the sharpness test.
To find out how sharp
your weapons are,
I will cut through these
rolled-up tatami mats.
Now, unlike the
strength test, this
is all about what the
edge of your weapon
will do to these mats.
Justin, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Rock and roll.
All right, do that.
[heavy metal music]
All right Justin, let's
talk about the cuts here.
Clearly, on the other cuts,
they cut all the way through.
On the last cut, almost, but
just a little skin of that mat
is hanging on.
But it is a sharp edge.
Overall, sir, it will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Doug, your turn.
So you ready?
Let's see what
this thing can do.
Let's do it.
[heavy metal music]
All right, Doug.
First cut just went
so easy without a drag
that it went into
the next target.
It is a very sharp weapon.
It's very easy to wield.
And it's light.
Overall, sir, it will cut.
Thank you.
GRADY POWELL: First
of all, both of you,
thank you very much
for your hard work.
But as we know,
only one of you is
going to be leaving here the
"Forged in Fire" Champion
with a check for $10,000.
And today's "Forged in
Fire" champion is Doug.
Congratulations, you won.
Justin, unfortunately,
you're not gonna
be leaving with the win today.
And Doug is going
to tell you why.
Justin, on any other
given competition,
I can see your blade
being a champion's blade.
It is a beautiful blade.
But today, your opponent's was
just a little sharper, a little
lighter, and faster to wield.
Justin, again, thank you
very much for your hard work.
But unfortunately,
I'm gonna have to ask
you to please leave the forge.
Good job.
Thank you.
I'm glad that this time
frame worked out as it did.
Chemo takes a toll on your body.
But going through
that and then do
this whole competition just
goes to show myself how much
I can actually push through.
I've always kind
of been stubborn.
But I never realized how
stubborn I am, actually.
Well, Doug, you are the
"Forged in Fire" Champion.
Congratulations, man.
Thanks a lot.
[applause]
What are you gonna to
get with that $10,000?
Oh, I fell in love
with a forge press.
[laughs]
I definitely want one
of those of my own.
I'm ecstatic.
You know, I put a
lot of heart and soul
into making that blade.
And seeing it perform
the way that it did
was just a really
great confirmation
about my abilities.
And it's just making me
want to make more knives.
[heavy metal music]